okay what up guys welcome to the just
pearly things youtube channel today i
have morning coffee thoughts even though
this is a smoothie
but i also have coffee because
i'm a weak person i don't know what to
tell you
so before i start don't forget to
subscribe to the channel like the video
i'm so tired of you ninja watchers and
also also
join our memberships it's like five ten
bucks a month it helps support the
channel and plus i'm trying to get a
bigger place i want to get a giant ass
place to film in next year if you think
our set is good now imagine
if the guests aren't sweating and we're
in a giant place so i have two months to
get like the most members so i have a
consistent form of like rent i know i
can like pay it anyways
that's why you should support the
memberships but you know don't let me
tell you what to do so today
i want to talk about
how
interesting the internet is
and i was thinking about yesterday
i saw a hate video on me
and i think i like hate videos because
i'm like you cared enough to make a
talk about me with the whole panel of
people oh my god it was so funny it
wasn't really a hate video it wasn't
that bad they did say that i looked like
a dog which is a little offensive but i
was like you know what i could be a
worse animal it could be like an
orangutang
and
i always get mixed when i talk about my
hate comments i'll get two things in the
comments section like one group of
people will be like well if you didn't
care you wouldn't talk about it at all
and i'm like
maybe i guess i care a little bit
but part of me thinks they're like funny
like it's almost endearing to me any
anyways
but
i think that hate videos gas up people's
egos
and i was thinking about this because
you think you're more important than you
are
and i thought about this when i was
dating a guy
last year and he was a bigger like
he was on social media too and so i met
some big social media people
and when i walked into the room with
those social media people it was like
and these these people were like
on tick tock like one of the biggest
people on tick tock and they almost like
expected me to know the drama that was
like going on behind the scenes
and i remember thinking like i don't
care at all
i don't care i don't know what people
are saying about you guys
um
i don't know what happened don't don't
care and it's almost like
when you see these videos you feel like
all eyes are on you when nobody cares
and i was thinking about it i'm like i
think in general hate videos
while you may think
you may think they make people insecure
and they hate them
but i think the opposite effect happens
i think it makes people think they're
more important than they are okay
and and it makes people think
that everyone's like talking about them
so i think it gives you a bigger ego not
a smaller
plus
on tick tock if you guys want a formula
for like doing good on tick tock i'm
gonna give you this
reply to hate comments oh my god
people love to see you just reply to
hate comments like i don't know what it
is
i just every time i do it the videos do
good
i'm actually banned off a tick tock for
a week
so
guys yesterday
i almost threw a punch
i know you're thinking
you pearl throwing a punch yup
this this whale okay
you guys are gonna see the video monday
so this is kind of a promo for this
video
august 1st okay it's dropping this whale
had the audacity
had the audacity
to try to fight me like she's calling me
a slag she's like
and all because i said this is this is
what set her off i said
because feminists always argue with me
they're like well i just want to be able
to walk alone
i'm like honestly i can walk alone at
night in most places
i'm just just to be fair like i don't
live in a great area i live in
i mean it's getting better it's like on
the up and up like i think i call it the
hood because i think it's funny
i think people from the actual hood
would think it's not a hood and people
from like a nice area would think it's
the hood so it's like
it's like in between right but honestly
i walk i've walked alone at night i've
been fine i'm not too worried about it
um
so to be just to be fair but i just said
i'm like you're not entitled to security
are you are you insane
i'm like ma'am ma'am
and i said you're acting crazy because
her and her friend were like
and i'm like you're not entitled to
security and this woman tells me
and i say if if you walk alone at night
in a dangerous area you might get
attacked man or woman
sorry
and this set the [ __ ] off oh my god
she's like
like
you have to see the video i'm not going
to show it to you i wish i could no my
manager would kill me my manager i'm not
going to do it but
i've never thought about hitting anyone
in my life i've never thought about it
oh i was close but i was like i talked
to my dad about this i because i always
ask my dad about things i'm like dad can
i throw a punch and he said
no you have too much to lose and i guess
if someone assaults you even if you hit
back like then it's like double assault
or something
so i just bring security now
i'm doing a mirror i had a guy
and
shout out jesse you know shout out
so you know thank god
but
drink some water too it was like a
little
but
anyways i was just thinking like welcome
to world star [ __ ] oh my god this this
clip is hilarious i was so mad at the
time
that i couldn't
oh my and then so she called me a slag
first of all i don't know what a slag
means so i'm like if you're gonna insult
me
i know british people use this to like
consult each other i'm like if you're
gonna insult me at least use a word i
know
at least use the word i know
cause i'm not smart enough to know these
words
and i tell her i'm like you're a [ __ ]
whale
now look it
i i personally don't even feel like i
insulted her i just said what was
i just gave a description
and i said you're a grown ass woman why
are you acting like this how are you how
are you a functioning adult because she
looked like she was like 35 i'm like how
are you 35 and you act like this i don't
understand i don't care how drunk you
are or what the [ __ ] you're on
like there's no excuse for acting like
that at 35 years old i'm like
anyways
video drops monday um get excited
third third piece of tidbit
i don't even know what i'm talking about
today but third thing
i hate when i interview people on the
streets okay
and they consent to the interview they i
say do you want to interview you they
say yes
they get up
i have
and then after they want me to pull the
footage no
no you consented to doing the interview
you can't withdraw consent after
this isn't great
if you don't want to meet like
after you can't just because you
regretted it you can't
the audacity this dude too came back he
interrupted a different interview that i
was doing to come back to talk to me
anyways
things i deal with day to day
real though i genuinely think hate
videos give people bigger egos and not
smaller ones
that's my opinion and i've decided this
so let me know in the comments
what you guys think also if there's a
trainer in east london
i'm trying to i've been stuck at the
same weight for like two months
and i know it's my own personal
decisions i know it's my own fault but
i'm done i'm losing this last 20 pounds
i've lost 20 i'm losing 20 more i've
done being stuck at this weight i will
do some sort of incentive where if you
can get me off this last 20 pounds i'll
pay you x amount of dollars i don't know
what it is
you tell me you tell me what you want so
like the video on your way out comment
subscribe
i'll talk to you guys later